okay but now what I want to do is I want
to think about can I understand this a
little more easily rather than like
working with this function that I don't
know what it is which is a bit awkward I
have no equations here I'm just trying
to piece it together right what I'm
going to do is instead of drawing a
displacement time graph displacement and
time I am going to draw a velocity and
time graph velocity in time the reason
why is because I know what velocity is
so this will actually be very easy to
graph okay so enjoy yourself maybe if
you can't directly underneath it where
you're actually easier for you but I've
run out of space directly underneath
draw yourself a new set of axes and I'm
going to mark out the same time
coordinates one two and three
here's still an x time axis right so
this is still X but what I've got over
here is not displacement anymore it's
going to be four s'ti now because
velocity is a rate of change
it's how displacement is changing over
time that's why I can say it's f dash
right hey you guys we've seen this
before right
you've been able to graph f dash from F
well what would it look like in this
case what's happening for the first two
hours it's straight right but watch out
it's straight at what value what is the
velocity from time 0 to time - it's 60
right so I guess 60s are there I'll put
60 here is that okay so for the first
two hours that velocity is just 60 is
that all right I'll put a marker in here
I'll make this a hollow circle because
in a second is allowed to change isn't
it they're going to speed up so now it's
going to be 100 kilometers per hour
from the second hour to the end okay so
that's probably something about that
roughly you get the idea they go forever
okay now
orange is the color I used my question
is the way we solve this this problem
here of our fart of the astronaut travel
what does it look like on this diagram
what does solving this question look
like over here we had to use like find
out where you end found out you start in
and take the difference okay but in this
diagram from time one to time three
where is the number 160 where is the
answer this where is it hiding okay
hmm before we come to the what do you
reckon I will come to you okay I want
you to think about how you inferred each
part of this graph right how did you
work it out for example when it was the
gradient changing what is that happening
because the speed changes right and the
speed is literally the gradient here
okay and that's why over here you can
see these values change because this
graph is about the gradient
okay so you can see on this graph it's a
little clearer that these two legs of
their journey the slow part and the fast
part can be considered as two separate
pieces do you see that if I draw a line
down the middle like that
okay so there's like journey part one
journey part two yes Eric what were you
going to suggest what were you thinking
add a hundred to sixty just the whole
room a second this is a very obvious
calculation to do but why where is it on
this diagram okay well there's the slow
part of a journey right grab your color
there and show that in see that spot
there okay traveling at 60 kilometers
per hour for how long and the answer is
for one hour right one hour
times 60 kilometers per hour now please
note had I asked you for a different
spot right if I'd said well what about
from one and a half hours to three hours
right what would I have done here
instead of going 1 times 60 what would I
have done I would have gone half an hour
times times 60 which of course would
have been 30 kilometers which is how far
you travel at that speed in that time
okay so this is 1 times 6
because it's one hour times 60 km/h you
can even see what happens with the units
do you see that do you see why we write
per hour as divided by out because the
hours they literally the cancel right
and that's what leaves you with 60
kilometres okay what about over here
well I've got another part of the
journey but of course it's going faster
right so how am I going to work out what
this part is it's one hour multiplied by
a hundred kilometres per hour so it's 1
times 100 same deal with the unit's
right hour colonna's per hour okay so
these two here represent two parts they
journey you do one you do the other and
then of course because you do them one
after the other you add them that gives
you a total distance which is thankfully
60 plus 100 which is 160 okay all right
now what have we just done right well
we've solved this problem here based on
this graph but it was a little bit weird
because we didn't know what any of the
UM any of the actual equations were
right but now I've converted it into a
graph where I know it looks like a
reader graph because it's a bid it's a
step function right
it's a piecemeal function but I can work
out the values quite easily because
they're all rectangles they're easy to
deal with okay so what we've done is we
turned like a something like sort of a
gradient problem into a well it's an
area problem isn't it you see that like
that's how you work out this distance
here and that's why you do if it was
half the time you'd make the rectangle
half the size does that make sense
now before I formalize this and put some
language around it write some notation
just to imagine if it wasn't such a
simple journey right if it wasn't 60
kilometers exactly for two hours what if
it was like I don't know 35 kilometers
for two minutes and then 71 kilometers
for 45 seconds and it just kept on
changing right I could still do this
couldn't I it would just be Messier but
it would be the same thing just like
more calculations does that make sense
in principle the idea is sound working
out areas gives you a total change
okay